die welt schaut weiter mit sorge auf
russland und die ukraine in reaktion auf
putins handeln haben die eu und usa
sanktionen beschlossen die auch folgen
für uns haben könnten zum beispiel noch
höherer energiepreise außenministerin
baerbock stellte heute klar frieden und
freiheit in europa haben kein
preisschild aber was heißt das für
unsere wirtschaft die sich nach corona
gerade erholt und sind sanktionen
überhaupt das richtige mittel um den
konflikt zu befrieden welche instrumente
hat der westen und was hilft der ukraine
kriegsangst in europa was kann coating
bremsen unser thema in der 5
[Musik]
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen aus berlin ich darf
meine gäste vorstellen ursula weidenfeld
ist bei uns freie
wirtschaftsjournalistin und kolumnistin
bei t-online und ich begrüße alexander
rahr einer der führenden russland
expertin putin biograf lange jahre
verantwortlich für den petersburger
dialog erarbeitet als berater unter
anderem für gazprom und zugeschaltet ist
uns professor clemens fuß er ist
präsident des ifo-instituts
und herzlich willkommen ralf molina
basina herzlich willkommen journalist
ehemalige hörfunk korrespondent des
westdeutschen rundfunks in brüssel und
in washington
wer jetzt haben wir ein beschluss der eu
und auch der usa von sanktionen
einreiseverboten vermögen sollen
eingefroren werden
zugangsbeschränkungen zu kapitalmärkten
und eben auch das vorläufige aus von
nord stream wird es putin irgendwie
überzeugen und kann man putin damit
sozusagen an den verhandlungstisch
zurück locken einen verhandlungstisch
mit gewalt nicht aber natürlich werden
wir sehen müssen wie die sanktionen
russland wirken ich glaube das sind
keine harten sanktionen in wirklichkeit
aber der westen signalisiert vor allem
die verein staaten von amerika dass das
der beginn sein könnte für eine absolute
abschaltung russlands von der westlichen
wirtschaft also dass man gewillt ist die
sanktion so weit zu treiben dass man
überhaupt kein handel mit russland hat
auch nicht gashandel auch kein erdöl
handel und russland weiß dass das nicht
umgehen kann ich warte jetzt auf die
gegen sanktionen von russland ich habe
keine ahnung wie sie aussehen werden
aber was wäre dann möglich ja was meinen
sie was da möglich ist ich glaube es
werden asymmetrische sanktionen
durchgesetzt und durchgeführt werden die
uns gar nicht mal wirtschaftlich treffen
sondern politisch und nun zum beispiel
wird man das habe ich in moskau jetzt
gehört ein vorschlag zum beispiel den
westlichen fluglinien zu verbieten nach
asien über russland zu pflegen das wird
uns unmenge viel geld kosten ich hoffe
nicht dass es dazu kommt eine andere
aktion ist eine militärische
militärstützpunkte wiederzueröffnen auf
kuba und venezuela damit die amerikaner
dort wieder anfragen aufzurüsten um
diese länder auch auch zu kontrollieren
die sanktionen die jetzt beschlossene
würden eher zu einer stärkeren reaktion
ich führe nicht dazu werden sie russland
einlenkt wenn sie mich fragen also ich
könnte mich irren aber das ist meine
also mein eindruck dass jetzt die russen
mit asymmetrischen reaktionen und
sanktionen versuchen den westen in die
schranken zu weisen ok er fußt wie sehen
sie ist die jetzt beschlossenen
sanktionen was denken sie welche wirkung
können die entfalten was bedeutet das
für russland
ja ich denke auch das sind zunächst
einmal signale die praktischen
konsequenzen sind recht überschaubar das
wird in russland keinen so großen druck
ausüben aber das signal ist klar zum
beispiel nord stream 2 ist er bedeutet
ja
langfristig wird europa nicht wie
geplant mehr gas von europa vom von
russland kaufen sondern weniger das ist
schon ein ökonomischer schaden der
angerichtet wird es ist klar dass das
kurzfristig nicht sehr viel bewegen wird
aber ich denke es ist ein signal ist
auch ein signal für einigkeit unter den
europäern putin hat ja starke anreize
versucht dass auch die europäer zu
spalten oder die amerikaner und die
europäer auseinander zu dividieren und
man hat versucht das signal zu geben so
einfach geht s nicht man sollte aber
nicht zu viel von diesen sanktionen
erwarten ist eher die dass auch das
signal da kann noch mehr kommen herr
sina einigkeit in europa das war nicht
immer so sie haben das ja jahrelang aus
brüssel auch beobachtet ist das ein
punkt wo man sagt da hat sich etwas
verändert und deshalb ist wäre man auch
bereit sozusagen noch mal härtere
sanktionen zu verhängen damit man
wirklich auch weiß es hier funktioniert
das und europa spricht mit einer stimme
in
der tat putin ist ein wunder gelungen er
hat die root zusammengeschweißt in einer
weise wie ich das in brüssel noch nie
erlebt habe dass sie innerhalb von 24
stunden sich auf sanktionen hat einigen
können ganz beachtlich obwohl es bei
einzelnen eu-ländern ja auch bedenken
gab es zb bei italien man muss wissen
italien hat keine kernenergie hat keine
kohle ist voll von erdgas abhängig und
im klartext voll von russischem erdgas
hat trotzdem zugestimmt also das ist
eine beachtliche stärke die eu gezeigt
hat allerdings hält es auch einige eu
staat gegeben zum beispiel die
baltischen die gesagt hätten dass uns
gleich viel schärfer ein signal setzen
härtere sanktionen jetzt von vornherein
um schlimmeres zu stoppen
wie sehen sie es was wird wird das
wirtschaftlich bedeuten wenn wir diese
sanktion umsetzen erstmal ganz wenig das
wird eben einzelne personen treffen das
wird vielleicht bei den staatsanleihen
und bei den bankbeziehungen größeren
schaden anrichten aber da gibt es immer
noch auch wege das zu umgehen und das
irgendwie anders dann zu regeln es ist
tatsächlich glaube ich schon auch so
dass sanktionen gegen russland
die nicht den energiebereich betreffen
die nicht den finanz verkehr betreffen
eben eher symbolischen charakter haben
sich auch eher gegen einzelne personen
richten als gegen eine gesamte
volkswirtschaft und auch die die dann
die energie betreffen würden oder die
den finanz verkehr betreffen würden dann
eben bei der abwicklung des
zahlungsverkehrs die ja möglicherweise
oder wahrscheinlich später dann kommen
die würden eben auch russland vermutlich
eher mittelfristig beeindrucken als
morgen eine veränderte situation
herbeizuführen
das werden sie nicht tun weil russland
sehr sehr gut vorbereitet ist auch auf
sanktionen russland hat enorme
devisenreserven über 500 milliarden
dollar umgerechnet enorme goldreserven
die können schon sehr lange aushalten
ohne weiteren also ohne weitere zuflüsse
von von westlichen geld zu haben also
insofern swp schärfere sanktionen würden
wahrscheinlich mittelfristig eine
verhaltensänderung
möglicherweise auch nur herbeiführen
aber das was jetzt was jetzt beschlossen
ist es wird es hat eher symbolischen
charakter als das ist wirklich fragen an
das leid tun wenn es nur symbolischen
charakter aber ein
ganz wichtiger punkt ist ja noch zum 2
dass das jetzt sozusagen erstmal
vorläufig zumindest gestoppt ist und das
ändert ja nichts also noch zu zwei war
ja nicht im betrieb vorher das heißt
wenn ich das jetzt sanktioniere
untersage das geht nicht ans netz dann
treffe ich entscheidungen über
zukünftige wirtschaftliche beziehungen
aber nicht über die aktuellen also das
würde an der akuten lage russlands unter
der russischen wirtschaft der
volkswirtschaft gar nichts verändern es
war aber der ukrainische präsident hat
das sehr begrüßt können wir mal kurz
rein der hat sich heute auf einer
pressekonferenz genau dazu auch geäußert
wir begrüßen auch die entscheidung der
bundesrepublik deutschland die
zertifizierung von nord stream
aufs eis zu legen
ich möchte nur betonen dass diese
pipeline ist eine waffe gegen die
ukraine und das ganze ressort ich bin
fit
die pipeline ist eine waffe herum wie
wichtig ist das oder was bedeutet dass
das jetzt erst mal dieses verfahren
gestoppt ist er ist politischer schritt
kann wirtschaftliche umfeld hat ja recht
die banken parken war ja die funktion
abel sie hat praktisch auf dem
meeresboden gelegen und
das gas ist nicht durch geflossen und
ich muss sehen dass
natürlich die russen damit bestimmt
gerechnet haben ich weiß es nicht aber
ich kann mir vorstellen dass jetzt das
nächste opfer sagen wann der russischen
gegenaktion die ukrainische pipeline
sein wird und die ukraine ist auf das
transit monopol ja immer angewiesen
gewesen
die ukraine verdient 2 milliarden
us-dollar an den lieferungen russischen
gases durch ihr territorium und das ist
der größte batzen in dem
staatsbudget der ukraine wenn das
ausfällt
dann müssen wir weiter die ukraine
limitieren dann wird mehr geld in die
ukraine fließen müssen und darauf setzt
russland dass wir irgendwann mal sehen
müssen dass wir wenn die ukraine weiter
destabilisiert wird in dem dort
vielleicht kein gas mehr durch fließt
viel geld in die ukraine investieren
müssen und wir eigentlich gar nicht
haben und das ist ein problem vor dem
wir stehen er fußt wie würden sie es
einschätzen was bedeutet dass vor allen
dingen auch wenn man jetzt sieht die
energiepreise steigen stark an hat das
dann einfluss darauf oder ist es
wirklich eben auch dann wieder nur ein
symbol
ja die energiepreise steigen
das problem ist russland profitiert
natürlich von diesen steigenden
energiepreisen also mannschaft
unsicherheit und verkauft sein gas dann
noch teurer so lange hat man es noch
verkaufen kann
aber ich denke man muss schon sehen es
ist richtig russland kann maßnahmen
ergreifen die dem besten kosten
verursachen aber einen einen finanziell
eine finanzielle auseinandersetzung wird
der besten gewinnen im moment ist frau
weiten feld hat es gesagt russland gut
vorbereitet auch durch den hohen ölpreis
aber finanziell wird russland diese
auseinandersetzung verlieren russland
ist ein witz letztlich wirtschaftlich
ein zwerg bedeutet haben im energiemarkt
das russische bruttoinlandsprodukt zu
marktpreisen ist ungefähr so groß wie
das von spanien
das heißt zehn prozent der eu
finanziell kann russland diesen krieg
nicht gewinnen aber es gibt eben
strategische abhängigkeiten wir können
ja eigentlich wenige dinge tun die
russland wirklich weh tun wir können
nicht den gashahn zudrehen von unserer
seite
wenn wir die gasmengen reduzieren würden
würde wohl nur der preis steigen das
würde also bedeuten dass die einnahmen
vielleicht gleich bleiben in russland
und auch bei anderen sanktionen muss man
aufpassen es wird ja etwa viel über sehr
harte sanktionen wie etwa das ruft
system geredet aber da wie eben das gas
und die rohstoffe brauchen aus russland
müssen wir das ja auch irgendwie
bezahlen also das kernproblem besteht
darin dass der westen militärisch
derzeit russland nichts entgegenzusetzen
hat oder zu wenig und da dieser druck
nicht besteht
und da russland wo die wiso reserven hat
und da putin offenbar
schwer zu beeinflussen ist man kann
ihnen scheinbar auch nicht so recht über
die oligarchen familientreffen
ist zumindest kurzfristig da relativ
wenig zu machen in russland auch
vergleichsweise hoch ist also auch zu
zur putins politik so bizarr das ist
aber es gibt eben wenig was was ihnen
bremsen kann und was dazukommt und also
ich glaube anders als herr fuß dass der
westen natürlich seine sanktionen auf
den energiebereich jedenfalls in den
nächsten monaten ausdehnen könnte weil
wir ja einen relativ milden winter haben
es gibt eben immer noch 30 prozent gas
reserven in den deutschen gasspeichern
es gibt ja jetzt auch noch kohle um die
energieversorgung dann zu kompensieren
wenn gar sehr sehr teuer wird also es
ist nicht ganz aussichtslos zu sagen man
sanktioniert den energiebereich den
gasbereich der mann die wette macht dass
es dann vergleichsweise schnell geht und
das ist glaube ich das große risiko dass
man eben nicht wissen kann ob wladimir
putin dann in einem halben dreiviertel
oder in einem jahr ein denkt und vor dem
nächsten winter muss europa muss der
westen seine gasversorgung in
irgendeiner form wieder sicherheit
kein problem es gibt ja viele freie
kapazitäten glaube ich dass das die
korona pandemie eben die wirtschaft so
gebremst hat also korea hat ja noch sehr
große gasmengen die sie offensichtlich
auch abgeben würden an den europa es
gibt andere länder die noch reserven
haben die sie auch verkaufen würden
japan zum beispiel also für die nächsten
monate ist es nicht so schlimm aber es
waren eben teuer und irgendwie
amerikaner jetzt auch gesetzlich wollen
auch sanktionen gegen die
betreibergesellschaft eben ein internet
in den nächsten winter rechts nehmen er
für den nächsten winter reicht nicht
mehr es zeigt halt irgendwie abhängig
wir vom gas sind herr sina wir haben das
heute von der bundesregierung auch
gehört die airbag hat gesagt wir müssen
uns eigentlich auf höhere energiepreise
einstellen auch das flüssiggas aus
amerika ist teuer ist teurer was was
heißt das also diese abhängigkeit die
wir haben vom russischen gas sehen sie
da eine möglichkeit dass man das wenn
frau weidenfeld sagt wir müssen seine
einem jahr klar erklären dass wir das
überhaupt schaffen
es ist in der tat so dass die eu und das
deutschland das nicht einfach so eben
mal substituieren kann das was wir
beziehen an importmengen sei es jetzt
gas kohle oder öl lässt sich nicht
einfach schnell ersetzen und insofern
halte ich auch die kommunikation mit der
deutschen bevölkerung da für ganz
wichtig dass man sagt hier geht es
wirklich um einen existentiellen angriff
auf die demokratie es geht nicht nur um
die ukraine es geht nicht um
separatisten gebiete sondern es geht
darum einen sich demokratisieren das
nachbarland in seiner nähe auszuhebeln
und das ist ein angriff auf uns alle
und deswegen müssen wir da eine zeit an
dann auch höhere gaspreise ertragen also
ich glaube dass die kommunikation mit
der deutsche bevölkerung enorm wichtig
ist und eins muss ich noch mal sagen in
dem zusammenhang das aus für nord sind 2
das finde ich es schon ein paukenschlag
wenn man sieht wie lange der deutsche
bundeskanzler dem begriff gar nicht den
mund genommen hat und jetzt ist es
definitiv am ende und betroffen
betroffen ist einer der allerersten
vertrauten von putin ein deutscher
matthias warnig ein ehemaliger stasi
major den putin aus seiner kwb zeit in
dresden bestens kennt die beiden sind ja
zehn zu sagen ganz ganz eng und auch der
wird jetzt mit sanktionen belegt also
insofern ein wichtiges signal putin
funktioniert nicht allein auf dauer
funktionieren nur mit hilfe anderer und
die müssen durch strukturelle sanktionen
getroffen werden die frage ist aber was
ist die bevölkerung dann dann bereit
mitzutragen wenn sie sagen herr sie auch
als frau bär bank hat ja gesagt frieden
und freiheit hat den preis jetzt heute
gesagt ein demokratisches souverän ist
eine demokratische souveräne ukraine ist
uns auch wert dass wir auch
wirtschaftliche folgen dann haben auch
wirtschaftliche kosten herr fuß glauben
sie dass das funktioniert oder er hört
die solidarität dann letztendlich doch
beim preis auf
also ich fürchte ich muss doch
ich hatte einen fuß angesprochen
ja ich fürchte muss freiem feld wieder
sprechen also auf dem energiebereich
bringen singe sanktionen nichts wenn wir
uns vorstellen wir würden sagen wir mal
die gasimporte halbieren würde sofort
der welt gas
preis explodieren und die russen haben
schon auch möglichkeiten
insbesondere öl aber auch gas woanders
hin zu liefern man ich darf vielleicht
daran erinnern dass wir seit 2014
erhebliche wirtschaftssanktionen schon
haben gegen russland
die kosten deutschland 5 milliarden euro
etwa pro jahr der handel ist stark
zurückgegangen
die größten kosten liegen aber in
russland das hat putin überhaupt nicht
gestört und er weiß ja genau er muss nur
bis zum winter warten also das wäre ein
elfmeter für putin dann er wäre am ende
der sieger im herbst er kann das locker
durchhalten durch seine devisenreserven
und im herbst wäre er der strahlende
sieger in dieser angelegenheit weil die
europäer zu kreuze kriechen würden also
das denn sie können das gas nicht
ersetzt und davor kann man nur dringend
warnen nein ich glaube es ist
aussichtsreicher sich wirklich die
personen vorzunehmen ob das dann hilft
am ende weiß man auch nicht aber
volkswirtschaftlich ist das nicht so
teuer und wenn man sich die
oligarchischen familien deren banken
fahren denn die haben sehr sehr viele
vermögensanlagen in den usa in
großbritannien da muss man zugreifen
vielleicht auch mal etwas härter und
dann wird der druck auch putin steigen
auch wenn unklar ist wer da welchen
einfluss auf ihn letztlich hatte ich
glaube das ist deutlich aussichtsreicher
im energiemarkt gibt es nichts zu
gewinnen für die im juli ebenfalls
kurzfristig sie kennen putin lange und
gut haben bücher über ihn geschrieben
was kann putin denn beeindruckend wenn
er fuß sagt wenn man an die familien
geht an die oligarchen
das ist ja ein enger kreis auch der um
putin ist kann ihnen das bei uns
abgekapselt er hat sich abgekapselte
sieht sich als als großer herrscher in
russland der eine große aufgabe vor sich
hat sie haben durch diese sitzung des
sicherheitsrates gesehen die er jetzt
weltweit übertragen worden ist wo er
seine
engsten mitarbeiter die mächtigsten
menschen russlands versammelt hat und
jeder musste aufstehen und praktischen
schwur leisten dass er ihn unterstützt
um die politik der putin in der ukraine
vorhat durchzuführen nämlich die
anerkennung von lohans und dann jetzt
auch zu zu unterstützen damit hat er
eines getan hat die ganzen möglichkeiten
der oligarchen vielleicht über diese
leute an q gegen ihn zu planen
von vornherein unterbunden und ich
glaube das war genau die gleichen jetzt
leiden unter den sanktionen weil ihr
vermögen die leiden wie herr fuß richtig
gesagt hat seit sieben jahren darunter
aber ich möchte auch noch mal
wiederholen was herr fuß richtig gesagt
hat die russen haben inzwischen
alternativen die sie vor sieben jahren
nicht hat sie waren viel abhängiger von
von europa als als jetzt jetzt in die
abhängigkeiten weniger erst einmal sind
es ist die qualifizierung russland
selbst von staaten gelaufen und jungen
die russen selbst kaufen fast nicht für
weltmarktpreise aber trotzdem ihr gas
ein um gazprom verdient natürlich in
russland jetzt auch noch viel geld und
zweitens sie hat bauen ist die dritte
pipeline nach china
ja aber als jemand eine idee zu sein das
ist eine strategie die klar im westen
gesehen werden muss dass russland sich
orientiert von europäischen union nach
asien ja die dritte ist nicht fertig
aber die erste ist fertig es gibt in die
lieferungen die russland tätigt auch
nach japan übrigens nach südkorea im
asiatischen bereich und russland
versucht sich jetzt in asien
festzusetzen als energie macht und das
ist die alternative die kommt deshalb
werden auch viele die sanktionen gegen
den energiebereich hier nach hinten
losgehen weil die russen die
möglichkeiten haben sie haben sie noch
nicht also ich glaube dass das man da
schon also sie haben total recht wenn
sie die mittlere und die lange frist
angucken aber für den akuten fall also
für dieses und für das nächste jahr sind
die möglichkeiten eben noch nicht da
aber gut werden sie auch mit der
europäischen union weiterhin arbeiten
die das gras bitte nicht weg sah er die
frage ist ja was was kann man putin
anbieten wenn sie sagen hat da sind
genug dividenden das land ist
vorbereitet das wird keine militärische
hilfe geben herr sehen ja was was kann
die eu was kann der westen denn
sozusagen in die waagschale werfen damit
dieser konflikt eben nicht weiter
eskaliert
ich glaube der wichtigste verbündete für
die eu
ist das russische volk
und es ist zwar so wie er sagt dass
putin abgekapselt ist aber auch putin
ist nicht entgangen dass es in der
vergangenheit demonstrationen gegeben
hat in russland nicht nur in großen
städten und das ist das wofür er sich
wovor er sich fürchtet das ist auch das
was in der ukraine fürchtet den willen
der jüngeren generation zur demokratie
und für die eu ist die chance natürlich
auch die kommunikation mit dem
russischen volk zu pflegen und
klarzumachen dass das was da an
milliardenwerten geraubt worden ist von
oligarchen und nach europa unter anderem
transferiert wurde nach london aber auch
in die usa wo das hingegangen ist wie
das gewaschen wird und das ist
eigentlich eine waffe die für putin
super gefährlich ist die kommunikation
mit dem russischen volk dessen junge
generation über die sozialen medien
vernetzt ist navalny sitzt nicht umsonst
in haft es ist deshalb in haft weil man
fürchtet dass jetzt zum
kristallisationspunkt der opposition
wird und das ist eine wichtige chance
aus meiner sicht auch für die
europäische union herr würden sie dem
zustimmen
die aus westlicher sicht sieht es so aus
aber mein eindruck ist ein anderer dass
die russen jetzt in der krise zu
bestehen und zu zu ihren internationalen
nationale interessen und wenn sie fragen
was kann man putin anbieten so sind dass
weiterhin ich sage das ganz banal
verhandlungen über den stopp der
nato-erweiterung die nato erweiterung
ist ich werde wohl das immer immer die
immer wieder die mutter aller probleme
und so sehen das auch viele mitglieder
der der jungen generation in russland
sie mögen putin vielleicht gar nicht sie
sehen diese ganzen probleme aber wenn es
darauf ankommt die nationale sicherheit
des landes zu verteidigen sind sie mit
ihm das war immer so in der russischen
geschichte und ich glaube dass würde und
ansehen es wirklich eine richtige
militärische harte auseinandersetzung
gäbe mit der ukraine dann glauben sie
auch dass
kann ich mir überhaupt nicht vorstellen
dass mussten gegen die ukraine schienen
schießen umgekehrt kann ich mir nicht es
hat zwar schon ansatzweise diesen krieg
gegeben in einer ost ukraine mit
separatisten aber einen großen krieg mit
der besetzung von kiew mit bombardements
und kann ich mir nicht vorstellen
vor allen dingen wenn die russen selber
sagen dass die ost ukraine mit ihnen
zusammen ein gesamt an gemeinsam das
volk ist und mit jedem mit dem ich in
russland rede der seriös sagt mir
vergiss niemals wird tut hier nun die
ukraine angreifen das ist westliche
propaganda das jetzt versuche eine
hysterie aufzubauen das wird nicht
kommen wir wollen den dom was halten und
praktisch ja keine destabilisieren um
damit nicht in die nato kommt aber das
war es schon es wird kein angriff auf
die ukraine glaube man hätte auch nicht
gedacht dass putin jetzt in dieser woche
so reagiert wie er reagierte mit der
unabhängigkeitserklärung hat er hat
gegenüber stolz
dass ich geäußert also da hatte man ja
wirklich hoffnung also wie viel
vertrauen kann man da haben herr sina
sich schon den kopf also ich
lausche staunten als ich meine einen
start wie die ukraine ein un-mitglied
als nicht existent zu erklären als
dirigiert von ausländischen mächten als
manipuliert das ist der gipfel und
russische truppen stehen ja nicht nur in
den gebieten die von den separatisten
kontrolliert werden sie stehen auch
außerhalb sie sind in direkter
konfrontation mit dem ukrainischen
soldaten das hat erste tote gegeben wir
sind in einer kriegshandlung und für
mich ist nicht die frage was die eu
herrn putin anbieten sollte sie hat
genug angeboten max stundenlang zu putin
gereist scholz war da alle waren sie da
sie sind hin definiert was die eu sich
jetzt fragen muss was sie der ukraine
anbieten könnten zum beispiel
satellitenaufklärung über die die
europäische union verfügt über die
ukraine aber nicht dass wir eine
konkrete hilfe in diesem angriffskrieg
ich würde ganz gerne mal auf diese frage
der der wirt der wirtschaftlichen lage
und wirtschaftlichen konsequenzen kommen
herr fust wenn man jetzt sagt wenn du
wenn dieser konflikt weiter eskaliert
und wir haben schon das problem der
hohen energiepreise haben wir schon
angesprochen was heißt das für unsere
wirtschaft die sich gerade etwas erholt
hat ihr letzter
klimaindex war positiv nach der korona
zeit also was befürchten sie da wenn
dieser konflikte weitergeht
zunächst mal wenn die situation bleibt
wie sie jetzt ist also druck auf die
ukraine
sanktionen wie sie jetzt beschlossen
sind aber wenn es zum beispiel nicht zu
einer invasion tatsächlich kommt dann
sind die auswirkungen auf uns
überschaubar die energiepreise werden
höher sein als sie es ohne diesen
konflikt wären das wird die inflation
antreiben das sind aber keine effekte
wie bei uns den aufschwung kaputt machen
könnten wir müssen sehen die haushalte
in deutschland haben ersparnisse
gebildet in der pandemie mannes nicht
bereist man ist weniger als restaurant
und so weiter und das wollen die leute
ausgeben also die nachfrage wird im
sommer stark sein bei uns die
unternehmen haben volle auftragsbücher
wenn die pandemie tatsächlich nachlässt
da gibt es risiken zum beispiel in china
aber wenn sie wirklich nachlässt dann
wird es sicherlich auch die lage bei den
lieferketten verbessern und die
steigende inflation wird wegen dieser
steigenden nachfrage die kaufkraft nicht
abwürgen also wenn das alles so bleibt
glaube ich wird es trotzdem zu einem
aufschwung kommen anders ist es
natürlich wenn die krise jetzt ausweitet
wenn es ein massiver militärischer
konflikt gibt meint albert dann würde
der ölpreis stärker ansteigen und dann
werden wir in einer ganz anderen lage
aber dafür also das sehe ich derzeit
nicht
das wäre eine eskalation man muss atmen
ist es schwer putin zu lesen aber so
weit sind wir noch nicht verraten wir
sehen sich ähnlich optimistisch ja ich
glaube schon also wenn man den
derzeitigen konflikt ausblenden könnte
oder begrenzen könnte und ein frieden
könnte dann spricht nichts dagegen dass
wir in diesem jahr einen wirklich
kräftigen aufschwung haben werden der
sich dann möglicherweise sogar noch ins
nächste jahr dann auch deutlich zieht
weil ja die bundesregierung dann ihre
klima programme und ihre praktische wie
konjunkturprogramme noch mal dazu
wirkenden
investitionsprogramme machen will also
eigentlich sehen wir ohne diesen
konflikt zwei wunderbaren jahren
entgegen und wenn entspricht irgendwie
gerade nicht so ganz dem lebensgefühl
der menschen die das gefühl haben meine
güte ist wird alles teurer und die ja
aber das stimmt schon und alle sind
total genervt und wir sind am ende eines
schrecklichen winters das sieht das sehe
ich immer sieht er fußt ja auch aber
kaum auf die zahlen auf den arbeitsmarkt
wir sind was den arbeitsmarkt angeht
schon wieder auf besser als vor krisen
niveau also besser als 2009 10 wir haben
in ganz vielen branchen wirklich
auftragsbücher die bis in den sommer
reichen der bau boomt wie verrückt also
es ist jetzt die stimmung ist schlechter
als die lage und die lage ist jetzt
schon gut und die wird eben in den
nächsten monaten vermutlich also da
könnte in den nächsten monaten noch mal
richtig erfreulich werden trotzdem
erinnert uns diese krise jetzt noch
einmal sehr an die abhängigkeit eben vom
russischen gas zum beispiel das würde
hier hilft das sozusagen der neuen
regierung auf dem weg ausstieg aus das
ist ja das ist ja das große argument von
einem habeck der sagt wir müssen eben
einfach nur ganz viel erneuerbare haben
dann sind wir unabhängig und dabei
übersieht man glaube ich oder übersieht
auch herr h weg dass wir natürlich auch
bei den erneuerbaren abhängig bleiben
würden wir würden wasserstoff importe
immer machen müssen wenn wir grünen
wasserstoff haben wollen wir würden
vermutlich auch
weiterhin französischen atomstrom
importieren auch wenn wir den eigentlich
nicht mögen und den umwelt schädlich
finden und wir würden natürlich im
europäischen stromnetz strom auch
importieren aber dass man insgesamt mit
erneuerbaren unabhängiger von fossilen
rohstoffen wird wo wir zu 100 prozent
von ausländischen lieferanten abhängig
sind das ist ja relativ klar wenn das so
ist wenn wir weniger abhängig sind vom
russischen gas billiger
erneuerbare sind sind sind nicht
preiswerter zu haben er aber ist das
eine befürchtung die man auch hat das
wird dann letztendlich weniger
russisches gas braucht was bedeutet das
dann für russland habe ich schon gesagt
die russen werden mittel- und
langfristig sich auf asien konzentrieren
und haben diese entscheidung schon
getroffen aber ich erinnere noch daran
dass wir nicht nur gas aus russland
beziehen in riesigen mengen sondern auch
öl kohle immer noch was gebraucht wird
riesen kohle ich habe dass sie zahlen
nicht im kopf und rohstoffe und seltene
erde die wir gerade für unsere grüne
technologie so benötigen aus schwierigen
ländern auch kasachstan und deshalb
werde welche immer genau zu überlegen
wem letztendlich ich bin ja nicht gegen
sanktionen in dem sinn der westen musste
ja was tun als antwort auf
die
schlechter sind es kann ja aber man muss
überlegen dass die sanktionen
letztendlich nicht auf uns zurück
schlagen unserer bevölkerung mehr
schaden zufügen aus der brust ich
fürchte das geht nicht also man kann ich
nicht man kann mit einem weh tun und
dann erwarten dass man dass man selber
unbekannt dabei soll der muss man jeden
schritt genau überlegen als politiker
aber er aber man will ja auch das etwas
nutzt dass es hilft also her sehen da
würde ich gern sie noch mal fragen also
was wenn man jetzt härtere sanktionen
beschließen würde also war oder warum
tut die eu das nicht dass sie dann zum
beispiel ins system swift dass man die
russen davon ausschließt also dass man
wirklich merkt okay das ist tut wirklich
weh und dann ist man vielleicht kommt
man vielleicht schneller zum ziel
weil die eu in der tat in dieser frage
sich nicht ganz einig ist die baltischen
staaten oder ein staat wie polen hat
eine deutlich härtere haltung hätte auch
gleich am liebsten zu härteren
sanktionen gegriffen als das andere
staaten tun wie zum beispiel österreich
oder italien oder der putin freund
ungarn da gibt es also einen dissenz
deswegen hat das so nicht funktioniert
obwohl es in der tat aus meiner sicht
dringend notwendig wäre und ich glaube
das was auch großen sinn was im moment
in brüssel überlegt wird ob er nicht
auch physisch mal nach kiew geht also
wir diskutieren ja hier aus seiner
komfortzone heraus die ukraine ist
existenziell bedroht ukrainische mitte
überlegen auf die anoraks ihrer kinder
die blutgruppen darauf zu schreiben weil
sie so in sorge sind es ist eine
existenzielle situation für die ukraine
es wird die gesamte stadt gesamte
staaten system in frage gestellt das
muss man sich vor augen führen das ist
ja nicht irgendetwas sondern hier geht
es wirklich an die grundlagen und
insofern die diskussion in brüssel
sollen wir nicht zum beispiel den
auswärtigen ausschuss des europäischen
parlaments sich in kirchen treffen
lassen mit dem partner ausschuss des
ukrainischen parlament ist eine idee
zweite idee ein außenministertreffen der
eu in kiew annalena baerbock versucht
das im moment sind sie einige andere
noch nicht bereit so aber ich finde wir
müssen vor ort flagge zeigen könnte aber
sein dass das dann noch mehr provoziert
ferrari wurden sie ist das denn so
schwierig zu zu streiten so
widersprechen ich sage bloß nur diese
diese ukraine halb ist vielleicht jetzt
gerechtfertigt aber irgendwann mal wird
man ihr auch rational denken müssen mein
gott warum haben die ukraine in den
letzten sieben jahren den minsker
prozess immer wieder blockiert ja das
hätte doch eine ganz andere lösung geben
können wenn den dom bass gebieten
frühzeitig eine art von autonomie wie ja
festgeschrieben die ukraine selbst
unterschrieben hat gegeben worden wäre
dann hätten wir vielleicht dieses
problem was wir heute haben gar nicht
also und die finde auch dass in der
europäischen union ist natürlich viel
viel sympathie zur ukraine gibt für den
staat für die menschen vor allen dingen
osteuropa aber auch nicht überall aber
in vielen anderen ländern wird man sich
sagen werden wir wirklich ich sag mal
das wirklich sehr provozieren für unsere
sendung sollte man für die ukraine
weiterhin so bluten und das wird auch in
der bevölkerung hier auch in der
öffentlichkeit in europa eine sehr
schwierige frage vielleicht eine unfaire
frage aber diskutiert werden
ist doch ein symbol sie ist ein
dass das dass ein nato mitgliedschaft
der ukraine russland bedroht und deshalb
geht der streit über die ukraine seit 20
14 seit 20 14 das lager austritt seiner
mission ich habe ihn
ja es gibt keine nato mitgliedschaft der
ukraine
das waren deutsche wir haben die
amerikaner reden
die ukraine ist ein sich demokratisieren
das land das ist die gefahr für putin er
will nicht dass seine ehemaligen
satelliten sich demokratisieren weil die
demokratie das ende seiner in
anführungszeichen herrschaft und
karriere wäre das ist das was er
bekämpft es geht gar nicht nur um die
ukraine insofern finde ich ihren begriff
ukraine halb hoch problematisch es geht
ein angriff auf das demokratische system
putin will dass europa zerschlagen in
ein russisches und ein amerikanisches
das ist ein fernziel und das beginnt bei
der ukraine wo das endet das wissen wir
noch lange nicht und insofern finde ich
es gibt keinen ukraine hype sondern es
gibt eine zeitenwende die wir verdammt
ernst nehmen müssen wie würden sie sehen
wie stark die muss die solidarität von
deutschland von der eu mit der ukraine
stärker werden also ich bin mir nicht
sicher ob er
recht hat wenn er sagt wir brauchen hoch
symbolische akte für für kiew um klar zu
machen dass der westen ernst zu nehmen
ist und dass europa einen ernsten ein
ernsthafter partner am verhandlungstisch
ist mein eindruck ist eher dass es
solange der westen keine militärische
option für die ukraine in betracht zieht
und das kommt ja nicht in frage das will
niemand dass wir in europa niemand das
wollen die amerikaner nicht so lange
wird es bei sanktionen bleiben müssen
und da ist eben natürlich die frage wie
lange macht man das und wie hoch ist und
wer spürt es am ende und ich glaube
schon dass es so sein wird sollte im
nächsten winter deutschland
kalt da sitzen
jetzt um die man jetzt treffen aber
maßnahmen die man jetzt trifft werden
keine unmittelbare wirkung haben er fußt
wie funktioniert das mit sanktionen wann
treffen sie wen am härtesten von
russischer seite hört man ja auch oft ja
das wird dann auf der die ärmere
bevölkerung treffen wenn der westen
seine sanktionen da ausübt also wie wo
was würden sie sagen was wäre ein guter
hebel und wenn man es eben noch wenn man
härtere sanktionen machen würde die
hätten eben ganz andere konsequenzen
also ich fürchte die geschichte der
wirtschaftssanktionen stimmt da nicht
sehr optimistisch ist es gibt eigentlich
wenig fälle in denen es gelungen ist
diktatoren oder aggressoren in die knie
zu zwingen mit wirtschaftssanktionen
selbst wenn man den iran denken da hat
man ja sehr sehr hart sanktioniert aber
dass
das das regime doch das wird auch nicht
geklappt und das regime ist immer noch
da nein ich glaube wir müssen das ganze
hier vom ende her denken also wir wenn
wir die vorstellung haben das wird dann
wenn da eine verhandlungslösung geben
dann ist klar man muss überlegen beide
seiten müssen einigermaßen
gesichtswahrend aus der nummer
herauskommt wie man aus einer
verhandlung heraus kommt das hängt davon
ab wie man hineingeht bzw was passiert
wenn man die verhandlungen abbrechen da
die europäer müssen also überlegen in
diesem vielleicht länger andauernden
verhandlungs spiel wie können sie
stückweise ihre position verbessern und
die von putin schwächen und ich glaube
da muss man an vielen fronten ansätzen
einmal die helsana sagte muss man
darüber nachdenken informationen die die
russische bevölkerung erreichen da gibt
es ja eine riesen propagandafeldzug aber
durch soziale medien kann man dem
entgegentreten
wir glauben auch nicht so an symbolisch
außenminister versammlung also da gibt's
schon fast zu viel in der eu das wirkt
schon einmal so als müsste man es nicht
mehr ganz so ernst nehmen da ist ja
einer nach einem einer nach dem anderen
nach moskau gefahren und putin hat sich
dahin gestellt und sich nicht mit denen
unterhalten und dann hat er genau das
gegenteil von dem getan was erwartet
wurde das war ja schon peinlich also ich
glaube das müssen wir nicht verstärken
sondern man muss die oligarchen unter
druck setze es mag schon sein dass er
sich abschottet aber kein politiker der
welt kann es sich mit allen mächtigen in
seinem land verscherzen noch nicht mal
putin das heißt er muss dann zumindest
mehr energie darauf verwenden die
oligarchen bei sich zu halten dann muss
die kosten für den konflikt erhöhen und
nicht zuletzt wir müssen die ukraine
stützen da müssen müssen wir uns
überlegen was kostet uns der schutz
dieses landes was kostet das sollte uns
das kosten bereit sind wir auch zu
wenden um putin einzudämmen aber im
vergleich zum militärischen intervention
ist es wahrscheinlich relativ billig
also das land blutet derzeit
wirtschaftlich aus wir müssen
deutschland unter 3
aber die leute unterstützt die ja genau
das muss ausgeweitet werden so
wahnsinnig stark ist es nicht und das
muss die eu insgesamt leisten das ist
was wir sind alles wege
putin er zur verhandlung geneigt zu
machen und ihn unter druck zu setzen
allzuviel dürfen uns davon nicht nicht
erwarten aber ich glaube nur so kommen
wir in einer situation bei der es dann
verhandlungen geben kann und in der tat
müssen da so dinge wie
nato-mitgliedschaft auf den tisch was
ist da derzeit fahrt das muss alles auf
den tisch und dann kann man erwarten
dass man irgendwie mit einem blauen auge
aus diesen verhandlungen herauskommt
ja natürlich auch ja wichtiger teil ist
natürlich auch die militärische
komponente also ist es wichtig dass die
nato aufrüstet truppen aufbauen da genau
das passiert derzeit auch im baltikum
all das wird putin unter druck setzen
und wird ihm geneigter machen zu
verhandeln
herberg auf bewerber gefunden
abgekapselt da auf wen hört er dennoch
es ging ja es gab vorschläge dass zum
beispiel herr schröder vielleicht noch
mal mit ihm verhandeln sollte frau frau
schröder kim hat geschrieben bei
instagram viele haben sich bei mir
gemeldet ob mein mann nicht mit herrn
putin über die ukraine krise reden
könnte das ginge nur wenn die
bundesregierung das ernsthaft wollte
oder ist aber nicht auszugehen aber wäre
er gleich das hätte schon unter merkel
passieren müssen personen wie schröder
und andere sollen hier nicht verteufelt
werden weil sie die nähe zur putin haben
sondern benutzt werden als sehr wichtige
brücken [ __ ] nach rust hat nach punkten
vertrauenswürdige gespräche führen wie
gern schon damals mit der
geheimdiplomatie als fotokopie befreit
wurde das funktioniert so kann man mit
büttenreden auch parteien im spiel der
sg maliger bundeskanzler und trägt
verantwortung für das leben und die
sicherheit deutschlands hat sich doch
als partei auch in den letzten wochen
ändern er muss ändern er muss für beide
seiten als vermittler ins spiel kommen
und in der tat ist es so dass putin aus
meiner beobachtung mit schröder sehr gut
kann also da würden sie noch sagen da
gibt es noch eine möglichkeit ich habe
in erinnerung wie genscher damals die
geheimen gespräche geführt hat und
dietrich genscher awami partei gerhard
schröder ist
steht auf der gehaltsliste von gazprom
und er hat sich in den letzten zwei
wochen nicht so geäußert als wurde er
vermitteln ok sondern als stünde er auf
einer seite war eine chance gut
ist dann auch vertagen gute ich kenne
aber sonst niemand in europa der ein so
gutes verhältnis zum jetzigen
abgekapselten putin hat ok also das
macht das schwieriger und ist es dann
die der eindruck richtig dass es
letztendlich wirklich an putin alleine
liegt diesen konflikt zu befrieden und
am besten ankommt der mädchen und gegner
nicht wir haben 68 damals niemand
erinnert sich daran den einmarsch in
prag gehabt sieben jahre später es war
fast der dritte weltkrieg der daraus
entstandene sieben jahre später hatten
wir die osze dicker als idee also eine
verständigung mit der sowjetunion damals
über gemeinsame sicherheit gemeinsam und
wirtschafts aufgaben auf dem
europäischen kontinent
vielleicht geht das in diese richtung
irgendwo anders
ich glaube nicht dass putin aus sich
heraus alleine funktioniert er
funktioniert auf keinen fall so als
hätte er nicht so panische angst vor
jemand wiener wahlen die so zu den ich
versuchen seine
oppositionellen zu liquidieren zu
vergiften und sonst was putin ist ein
hoch ängstlicher mensch und er weiß wo
die gefahr sitzt er weiß um die junge
opposition er weiß um die leute die über
die soziale medien vernetzt sind und ich
finde wir müssen den russischen
außenminister lawrow kopieren wenn nord
stream 2 gestoppt wird was macht lavant
verwendet sich mit deutschen schließt an
die deutsche bevölkerung wir müssen uns
viel stärker an das russische volk
wenden das ist unser wichtigster
verbündeter
das ist der allerwichtigste dem wir
aufklären müssen wer das nicht die
informationen hat welche vermögen da
geraubt werden gewaschen werden
transferiert werden dass davon in weiten
teilen nichts weiß wir müssen mit dem
russischen volk kooperieren das ist der
eine punkt
andere punkt ist ohne die elite kommt
auch ein putin nicht weiter und wenn
jemand wie vanek ist ein stasi
vertrauter getroffen wird jetzt von nur
10 2 war nicht der mann der ceo der
deutschen abteilung von von gazprom dann
ist das mehr als gut und auf dem weg
müssen wir weitergehen wir können das
problem nicht militärisch lösen wir
können der ukraine satellitenbilder zur
verfügung stellen aber nicht mehr aber
über diese beiden schienen das volk ist
unser verbündeter und die legte muss
getroffen werden ja aber erst wenn das
volk das der verbündete sein soll dann
sind doch sanktionen auch nicht das
richtige mittel oder die ich treffen das
volk na ja also ich glaube das ist schon
wichtig sich an diesen momenten aber zu
viel sollte man sich davon nicht
zu viel soll man sich davon nicht
versprechen ich glaube das ist nur ein
baustein alleine das wird nicht reichen
man muss eben gegen diese propaganda
natürlich sich wenden putin wird seinem
volk jetzt sagen der westen verhängt
sanktionen und schädigt euch und das ist
ja in gewissem umfang auch richtig
deshalb ist es eben so dass man ehe ist
besser als sanktion zu wählen die
gezielt bestimmte gruppen treffen und da
würde ich eben sagen die man musste
wirklich die elite treppen das ist schon
richtig also muss die familien die
großen unternehmer treffen und ab vor
allem die ausländischen aktiver
einkassieren also wenn putin mächtige
unterstützer verliert oder wenn wenn
diese an der wohlstand so der reichtum
dieser oligarchen davon abhängig ist
dass putin verhandelt dann wird das
zumindest druck auf ihn ausüben er ist
nicht vollkommen unabhängig von all
diesen leuten dafür sind die zu mächtig
frau weidenfeld wie optimistisch sind
sie dass dieser konflikt befriedet
werden kann ich kann das überhaupt nicht
einschätzen ein guter gesellschaft wenn
selbst der bundeskanzler dass nicht
richtig einschätzt wenn er zurückkommt
dann glaube ich weiß jedenfalls in
europa niemand wie das weitergeht gibt
es einen punkt wo sie sagen da haben sie
noch ein bisschen optimismus
ich habe alles gesagt durch verhandelt
und das auf dem russischen volk sich zu
werden ist schon richtig aber gut und
und schlau und intelligent und nicht so
wie das heute wiederum die balken tun
und die polin die sagen man darf
russischen staatsbürgern keine visa mehr
in die eu geben das geht nach hinten los
solche äußerungen sind katastrophal und
die zerstören genau das was beide herren
hier richtigerweise in bezug auf einer
zusammenarbeit mit der russischen
zivilgesellschaft gesagt haben also wir
sprechen nicht mit einer stimme okay wir
sind gespannt und werde natürlich noch
weiter darüber sprechen vielen dank
erstmal für diese diskussion frau
weidenfeld herr sina und her fust und
vielen dank liebe zuschauer ihnen für
das interesse und morgen kümmern wir uns
nochmal um dieses thema mit einer
anderen perspektive jetzt geht erst mal
geht es erstmal weiter bei phoenix der
tag mit mayer weber bis dahin tschüss
[Musik]